step one is to sit down and empathize
with the leaders of both Nations to
understand their history their concerns
their hopes
just had to open the door for
conversation so they're not back to the
corner yeah and I think the U.S can play
a really important role in a U.S
president can play a really important
role by reassuring the Russians that
we're not going to consider them an
enemy anymore that we want to be friends
and it doesn't mean that you have to let
down your guard completely the way that
you do it which was the way President
Kennedy did it is you do it one step at
a time you take baby steps we do a
unilateral move
reduce or you know our our hostility and
aggression and see if the Russians
reciprocate and um and that's the way
that we should be doing it and you know
we should be easing our way
into a positive relationship with Russia
we have a lot in common with Russia and
we should be friends with Russia and
with the Russian people and you know
apparently there's been 350 000
ukrainians
who have died at least in this war and
uh and there's probably been uh 60 or 80
000 Russians and that should not give us
any Joy it should not give us any you
know I saw
Lindsey Graham on TV saying you know
anything we can something to the extent
that anything we can do to kill Russians
is a good use of our money that it is
not you know those are those are
somebody's children they're you know we
should have compassion for them
um this war is an unnecessary War we
should settle it through negotiation
through diplomacy through statecraft
and not through weapons do you think
this war can come to an end purely
through military
operations no I mean I don't think
there's anywhere in the world that the
ukrainians can beat the Russians I don't
think there's any appetite in Europe I
think Europe is now you know uh in
having severe problems in Germany Italy
France you're seeing these riots there's
internal problems in those countries
there is no appetite in
um in uh in Europe for sending men to
die in Ukraine and the ukrainians do not
have anybody left the ukrainians are
using press gangs too uh to you know to
fill the ranks of their armies men
military age men
are trying as hard as they can to get
out of the Ukraine right now to avoid
going to the front the front you know
the Russians apparently have been
killing ukrainians in a seven to one
ratio
my son fought over there and he told me
it's not you know artillery he had
um he had fire fights with the Russians
mainly at night but he said most of the
battles were artillery wars during the
day and that the Russians now out uh
outgun the NATO forces ten to one in
artillery
oh they're killing at a horrendous rate
now you know my interpretation of what's
happened so far is that the
Putin actually went in early on
with a small Force because he expected
to meet somebody on the other end of a
negotiating table that once he went in
and uh and that when that didn't happen
they did not have a large enough Force
to be able to mount an offensive and so
they've been building up that Force up
to now and they now have that force and
even against this small original Force
the ukrainians have been uh helpless
all of their offenses have died they've
now killed you know the head of the
Ukrainian um
Special Forces which was the probably
arguably by many accounts the best uh
Elite military unit in all of Europe
the the common dance the commander of of
the uh That Special Forces Group
uh gave a speech about uh four months
ago saying that 86 of his men are dead
or wounded and will cannot return to the
front he cannot rebuild that Force
um the uh and you know the the the
troops that are now headed that are now
filling the gaps of all those 350 000
men who've been lost
are are scandily trained and they're
arriving green at the front many of them
do not want to be there many of them are
giving up and going over the Russian
side we've seen this again and again
again including platoon-sized groups
that are defecting to the Russians
and um I don't think it's possible to
win and anybody you know I saw I I of
course I've studied World War II history
exhaustively when I saw a
um there's a new I think it's a Netflix
series of documentaries that I highly
recommend to people there it's they're
colorized versions of the black and
white
um films from the battles of World War
II but it's all the battles of World War
II I watched Stalingrad
the other night and uh you know the the
willingness of the Russians to
um to fight on against any kind of
allies and to make huge sacrifices
of Russians the Russians themselves who
were making the sacrifice with their
lives the willingness of them to do that
for their motherland is almost
inexhaustible It is incomprehensible
to think that they are that Ukraine can
can beat Russia in a war it would be
like Mexico beating the United States
it's just it's impossible to think that
it can happen and you know Russia has
has deployed
a tiny tiny fraction of its military so
far and uh you know now it has China
with its mass production capacity
supporting its war effort it's just
it's a it's a hopeless situation and
we've been lied to you know we're the
press in our country and our government
are just are just you know promoting
this lie that the ukrainians are about
to win and everything's going great and
that
pollutants on the run and there's all
this wishful thinking because of the the
Wagner group you know the uh the Goshen
and the Wagner group that this was an
internal poo and it showed dissent and
weakness of Putin and none of that is
true I was a that that
Insurgency which wasn't even an
Insurgency he only got four thousand of
his of his men to follow him out of
twenty thousand
and they were quickly stopped and nobody
in the Russian military the oligarchy
the political system nobody supported it
you know and by we're being told oh yeah
it's the beginning of the end for Putin
he's weakened he's wounded he's on his
way out and all of these things are just
lies that we are being fed so they
pushed back on a small aspect of this he
kind of implied so I've traveled to
Ukraine and one thing that I should say
similar to the Battle of Stalingrad it
is just not is not only the Russians
that fight to the end I think ukrainians
are very lucky to fight to the end and
the morale there
is quite High I've talked to nobody this
was a year ago in August with her son
everybody was proud to fight and die for
their country and there's some aspect
where this war unified the people to get
gave them a reason and an understanding
that this is what it means to be
Ukrainian and I will fight to the death
I you know I would agree with that and I
I should have said that myself at the
beginning but you know that's one of the
reason
my son went over there to fight because
the you know he was inspired by The
Valor of the Ukrainian people and the
you know this extraordinary willingness
of them and I think Putin thought it
would be much easier to sweep into
Ukraine and he found you know a stone
wall of ukrainians whether it read it
but they're
their lives and their bodies online but
that to me makes the the whole episode
even more tragic is that you know
um I don't believe I I and I I think
that the U.S role in this
um has been uh has you know that there
were there were many opportunities
they settled this war and The ukrainians
Wanted settlements as a landscape when
he ran in 2019. here's a guy who's a a
comedian he's a he's an actor
um he had no political experience and
yet he won this election with 70 of the
vote why he went on a peace platform
anyone promising to sign the mystical
courts and yet something happened when
he got in there that made him suddenly
pivot and you know I think
it's a good guess what happened I think
he was you know he came under Threat by
Ultra natural and nationalists within
his own Administration
uh and the insistence of neocons like
Victoria new and the White House that
you know we don't want peace with Putin
we want a war
do you worry about nuclear war yeah I
worry about it it's uh it seems like a
silly question but it's not
it's a serious question well the reason
it's not you know the reason that it I
might it's not it's just because people
seem to be in this kind of dream state
about that it'll never happen
and yet you know we're uh it can happen
very easily and it can happen at any
time and you know if we push the
Russians too far you know I I don't
doubt that Putin if he felt like his
regime was in or his Nation
was in danger that the United States was
going to be able to
place you know a quizling on you know in
into the Kremlin
um that he would use nuclear you know
torpedoes
um and uh you know these uh these
strategic weapons that they have and
that could be the end once you do that
nobody controls the trajectory